good morning guys i'm here in milan with
the mythical that itt is italy see how
you are fine thank you
very well i'm very fine i'm very
happy to talk to you here in milan the
first time i come to milan and i come to
visit you how you had a great
time very well  apart from a little gray here and
there but for the rest I have to say this year they
collected the gray but in reality a
reality we enjoyed the sun
yesterday and the day before yesterday too so we
can't complain then the city is
alive so it's beautiful  i'm glad it's also a
greeting from the amazing matteo behind the
camera
ok so let's start as you can hear
we're speaking in italian in my
channel normally we speak in english
but since we're here with is it arjen
we wanted to talk about italian italian culture
and a lot of other
interesting things do you remember how it's done more
or less it's the first thing I wanted to
ask you is how the idea of
easy and time was born and how long have you been
working on it like  and all this has evolved
in Italy it is part of a
larger network called easy languages ​​the
concept is
to show how a language is spoken on
a daily basis so in our case
how Italians speak to each other
not in textbooks  and then
we go down to the street and
ask the Italians questions
so you can see a
natural conversation they are often
interesting questions so you also learn
something about the culture
one of the most interesting things about his
italia in the fact that katy is not actually
Italian but she is where you are from  that I'm
English is surprising because the first
time I met you I believe it
was in 2017 at the gag on Sunday
bratislava I didn't know where
this accent came from so clean in Italian
but maybe what do I know about some region of
Milan or surroundings then c  'she has a strange
vein of Neapolitan while talking
fine I said to him but maybe she's a
Milanese of Neapolitan origin and then
he told me dear English so I'm
I was first of all stunned and surprised and the
second question that comes to me spontaneously and
then because this is a dog
on learning languages ​​is but
how the hell did you learn to
speak like this
is then first of all it must be said that in
any case I make mistakes
but I think that  sia
[Music]
at a certain point I realized that
I wanted to
get as close as possible to
Italians and Italian culture and
I could only do so by
learning Italian and so this
was a huge motivation for me to try
to improve my  Italian so
above all focus on the hundred for
example because the more your accent
resembles the accent of the person
you're talking to the
more you feel a connection and so in order
not to feel left out I had this
motivation to learn Italian
[Music]
here's how to say the  best possible
best possible in the best possible way
and interesting what you said
because it reminds me of a linguist who  I
often mention that it is called esteem in
what speaks of the fact and it is already a pdf that
you can download I leave you the link in the
description it speaks of the fact that very
often we tend to think that to
speak a certain language with an
almost perfect pronunciation or native
we have to do a whole series of
exercises we have to stand there and
listen to repeat etc
etc which has a certain value
but in my opinion the most important thing
this is called a linguist it is called a
hold they cross and this is called
a class filter
in my opinion the psychological component and
incredibly relevant
yes yes because I also noticed for example in
the first year I wanted to get as close as
possible to Italian culture so
I concentrated a lot
on the accent and then at a certain point
I noticed
at a certain point I realized
I really got high  the question but I
want to completely discard English identities
or I had a bit of a crisis
and at that stage it could be  I
'm imagining it but I swear my
English accent has returned a little more
because
yes because in that phase I felt a
little more English so in my opinion
the accent is the identity they are two things that
absolutely cannot be separated  yes
I agree 100 percent ok
so basically
let's say that your way of learning to
acquire the accent weighs heavily
on the desire to identify
with Italian then there was a
ping pong match between the 2  your identity
innings the english english your
identity in italian who played
ping pong or tennis but you did some
concrete work to improve your
pronunciation you were doing in essence yes
this too in fact
the underlying motivation therefore wanting to
speak like an active but  then there are
also practical things that you have to do
or at least in my case
for example I didn't know how to pronounce the
Italian r and so I really did
some exercises in front of the computer or
under the  shower
while your dishes
let's start with the death and that
333 so i did this for months
practically then at some point
my r still isn't the same as yours but
at least that's how i learned to pronounce it i
wanted to point out a little thing for
those who are learning  Italian that the
Italian r actually also depends on the
place where you are I will give an example
in Rome the inter-vowel r i.e. between
two vowels is just mentioned for
example I can say brera listen to the r
brera in Milanese is brera for this  now
you hear a lot more so there are
various types of dr also it's not super a
double r but to go back to what
she said I did the same thing
too maybe not on consonants
or vowels but on words or entire sentences
and thorns  the shower at my place testing the
shower you practice therefore there is the
psychological component but there is also the component
strictly let's say of working on
articulation of sounds yes in my opinion I
don't know I don't know what but I a  school for
example I learned vocabulary
word lists grammar rules but
we never studied pronunciation and
so sometimes I think people have
this idea that pronunciation is a
magical thing that
there is either
you can pronounce or you have the accent  or
you don't have it and instead you don't
it's something that you can also
work on and improve by making an
effort and a little training I
subscribe to everything and relaunch saying that
whoever is absolutely right in
my opinion we have this mentality of all
o nothing o the talent to speak
well or not the talent to speak well
when in my opinion what matters
most is the will and the mentality and
obviously then a little bit of work
done well the combination of these three
things can lead to incredible results
seeing each other in italian
ok so we talked about how to
speak almost like a native what
you did to learn italian you
learn it at school he learned it each
other  iversity and who does what then
once you have finished university
concretely to learn so well I did
an Italian course at university
so I didn't study it as a degree
but he did a small course for two years that
's the interesting thing  is that after two
years
I didn't know how to speak a word of
Italian
I also remember a moment when I was
with a friend of mine and there was a pizza maker in
England Italian and he said to me come on come
on go talk to him about something I
tried to  have a very
simple conversation with him so where are you from and
all at the end my friend said
or something like this is she was
very embarrassed here she is facebook
he also pointed out to me that i couldn't
speak italian
while at one point so i  I
moved to Italy
I said to myself that
I saw many students
gaining experience abroad and coming back and they
didn't know how to speak the language because
they only had friends in
English friends or
friends from  their country and so I
said to myself
and I went exactly with the rule
I made a rule for myself in which I
said to myself I can't have friends with whom
I speak in
English it was very difficult at the beginning and
in fact I felt very lonely
because if  you don't speak a language well it's
not easy then making friends
but after
12 months of difficulty at a certain point
I started to be able to speak better
strength of doing a lot of practice
and then from there I learned to speak
Italian
ok so a little brute force method in
meaning you put yourself in the position of
having to speak Italian yes
this point is important because very
often we try to postpone the moment
in which they speak and therefore it says to
remain in my community it is then easy to
speak in English because
many people speak English but
bravo and factor  100 joint it was very
painful
it was painful for a long time but then the
interesting thing is that when I
realized that this was how it worked I did the
same thing p  to learn other languages
not living in the place so it's easy to
say to mature in Italy so they
learned Italian
but later learned
French luckily in a less painful way because
I did
little by little I did
conversation lessons so I discovered some
methods  to create situations in which you
talk a lot you listen a lot but
a little less less difficult let's say
that someone who
pays for what paid someone to
listen to me I felt less embarrassed
or even I did a lot of
linguistic exchanges because that's less
there is this agreement that you  you are learning
and therefore they have more she has more patience
so there are methods
to practice without necessarily having to
shell out money
yes
so basically you have used
the experience to learn Italian and she
applied it to French and what other
languages
and she applied what other languages ​​do you speak
to Spanish
then a little German is a little Chinese
ok and ask that you already knew
Italian here  going learned
french spanish which helped how
did you use the knowledge of italian
to learn french and spanish faster
it helped me a lot because obviously the
grammar is very similar
in fact it
is often said that it is more difficult because i
often hear people  who complain
because they say but now I always have a
background between Italian and Spanish
for me this is a normal phase and
you
just need to persevere persevere
because it happens at the beginning but it's
normal and so this returns to the
mentality  as soon as you find something
difficult don't stop and they will say
this thing happens then it means I
'm not good at languages
but no it's a normal obstacle that
if you continue then at a certain point it passes
what a wise woman you
are absolutely I just wanted to add
the fact that  like all things there is
always a there are always advantages and
disadvantages but there are many more advantages
when already knowing a language  a
certain group that you can use then
maximize the advantages when you learn
minimize the disadvantages for example
trying to speak both of you and your
case I imagine Italian is dominant
but if you can maybe practice a
little French Spanish every day or
have contact in this  way
maybe you can speak them all more or less
because when one language is more dominant than the
other then maybe if you go to speak
Spanish or
French Italian depends on the casinos it depends
on how you learn
and then a couple of other interesting things
there are
from my experience in my
experience there are a lot of
embarrassing situations you learn a
language unfortunately to find yourself in
position in position you have to find yourself
in embarrassing situations and
you too have made some
embarrassing mistakes so many a
few examples
then  the ones you can tell
you have the talent is
what troubled me the most
years after there  think again at night it was
because most of my learning
Italian was
informally so at the pub with friends
there were certain things I didn't know for
example doubles and so there's the
classic word year pre means he
spoke l  'Italian for a year before you
knew that if you mispronounced this
word
you would say year which means ines and when
I discovered this
oh God but I've probably been
going around for a year saying
hello, I've been
speaking Italian to you for a year
11  was exact and then
I had a phase in which I was afraid to
say this word and therefore I said
instead say year I said a little time
ago or since two decades
I've been learning Italian since two years half a
decade since a quarter of a decade illustrious is
if  I'm not wrong ten years just five years it
's 10 0 for I hope it's right for
half two years strangeness ours a few months
ago this thing happened instead of saying
last year he said
then this is a normal error I think
and in any case r  Ieto as I said before
learning languages ​​is a
phenomenal experience but you
will still encounter a series of
situations in which inevitably known
embarrassment says a strange thing that
seems strange but it is always learning
it is not always life so yes yes yes
absolutely
to learn a  foreign language you
must have a good self-deprecating sense of humor
absolutely because
otherwise the important thing in laughing about it is exact
from this most important rule in
my opinion then thinking about it he doesn't look back he
says oh god but heavens above yes
exactly then it's a beautiful  story to
tell in situations like this so
also to grandchildren good stories to tell
about
kids and everything for today thank you very much
for your attention thank you for
being here than in seven
and if you want to see a little more
interesting things about Italian on the
unity culture in italy italian to pizza and
dialects and everything else you can
click on the link in the description to
see the canaletti easy  italy where
you will also find a super
interesting video an interview we
did with luca guys and everything kisses
hugs from milan and see you soon
bye bye
let's go for a tour of milan let's go
because I only have one day left to
explore this wonderful city  hi
[Music]
h